on tv on radio and on your smartphone
this is talk tv
tonight on piers morgan and censored
with me jeremy kyle rail fails and pumps
up petrol prices are causing complete
misery for millions we'll ask what's
fueling britain's transport crisis and
how we can fix it record waiting lists
and diy dentistry who will heal the
national health service and as the race
for number 10 enters what feels like its
70th year we'll ask the tory party
deputy chairman if it's time to cut
short this ridiculous contest and fix
our country
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
good evening my friends a big welcome to
piers morgan i'm censored i'm jeremy
carl now all this week i've been using
my platform to talk about the cost of
living crisis and britain's summer of
strife tonight we're going to be talking
transport and i want you to spot the
words because this has been
painstakingly put together almost
everyone's had plans derailed by the
biggest train walkouts in 30 years that
mick lynch has ideas above his station
doesn't he more strikes than a 10-pin
bowler the three more are planned this
month and you can forget about london
underground they work less days than
santa claus but my friends at least
there's one faithful engine we can
always rely on
that's right thomas the tank engine that
faithful symbol of british railroad
reliability and service with a smile but
sadly no more
thomas is tanked i took my kid to see
him today there we are lovely sadly we
discovered on arrival that thomas
couldn't perform properly because it was
too hot apparently sparks from his
engine could cause fires in the hot
weather so he could only move 100 meters
in and out of the station so there you
have it my friends even thomas has
packed it in now there is of course a
serious side to this so let's get back
on track before i run out of steam and
lose my train of thought cost of living
it's not just public transport facing
crisis for many people the cost of fuel
is becoming a very serious problem
record prices mean just getting to work
for many is becoming too expensive the
cost of oil and gas made worse by the
war in ukraine is driving up prices and
squeezing supply so much so but today we
learned this is just extraordinary the
uk is now expecting planned power cuts
this winter
great
hold on hold on hold on hold on i've got
odin excuse me
hello
rob i need some money for the meter mate
we haven't got any cash left brilliant
we've got no cash bingo thank you very
much did you like that oh that was good
yeah right first tonight uh those
painful prices at the pumps fuel costs
have finally started to fall but they're
still near record highs the rac today
says the gap between four court prices
and wholesale prices is the widest in
almost a decade at the start of the week
the average petrol price at britain's
biggest four supermarkets was 174 a
liter diesel at 186. now we did some
research the cheapest place to fill up
is here dale head garage in halls in
north yorkshire great for the good
people of [ __ ] but it's 250 miles away
from the studio so my little fiat 500 in
brackets trying to sound like rishi soon
at close brackets that's close to 100
squid round trip just to get there
i wrote this so if you can't pop into
[ __ ] what can you do joining me now
thank you a financial expert gemma
godfrey here every night former a top
gear presenter and motoring legend steve
berry and my good old mate howard cox
from the campaign group fair fuel uk i'm
going to start with you howard um a lot
of people will talk about the difference
between the four court price
and what it costs you know the supplier
or whatever you're calling for a fuel
duty cut of 25 p per liter
quick question can we afford that
absolutely in the last year this
government is wallowing in an extra 4
billion of vat because of the high
prices and don't forget the vit is on
the duty as well it's a double taxation
and fundamentally as you mentioned
earlier the wholesale price let's get
this right june the first for example
was uh 30p or it's now 30p less than it
was in june the first why
and yet the retail price has gone up 4p
what what why what
i mean look
help me out
why aren't supermarkets lowering their
prices more
to almost save the motoring industry
because we are hearing real stories of
people who might not be able to get
their kids to school people who might
not be able to get to work i mean i say
it and i've said it with gemma every
night this week you wake up in this
country and you think what is next
people cannot afford petrol why is
something not being done but we're
talking about it and a lot of other
people are starting to talk about it i
think people nearly said something i
shouldn't i think people get angry
genuinely angry about this and i think
that's why we're having this
conversation and it's happening in homes
and workplaces and businesses and in
pubs all over the country people are
starting to ask that question why isn't
it lower why isn't the price been
lowered
and i think they're gonna have to react
and it's gonna some are reacting and
because the others have
they charge what they think they can get
but here's an interesting thing with
that research of the garage in great
halls it is people are queuing down the
road to go to that garage so does that
in a business way say to you that if
garages take the decision to be
competitive they will do better but i
don't understand again we're going to
bring it gemma back to the government
you know i watch these
two people vying to get to number 10
promising this promising that but yet
again nobody from the government front
and center saying we know you're
struggling in another way polio today
that's something else but but but why
howard to me it makes so much sense to
cut that and and reduce some pain for
people well we've got to ask is one is
to cut fuel duty germany have done it by
25b
france had done it by 20p
spain have done it by 20 billion island
17p we did it by 5p in march at the
spring statement and it didn't touch the
sides you didn't see it but i remember
that it was two quid a liter and he said
all this massive thing you take 5p off
and i remember that exact day gemma
right because and i think we talked on
the radio it was 195. it came down to
190 by the time i parked the car about
100 yards down the road that one had
gone to two quid it's not fair is it
it's not fair what we're seeing is
prices they're increasing prices very
quickly so it's not the case that
actually all changes take a lot of time
to implement very quick to increase
prices but they haven't decreased the
prices as much they should do and it's
real people people are playing now it's
a postcode lottery of where you live to
be able to get cheaper petrol
tips well okay so in terms of tips again
we've seen such a huge increase in
petrol prices that you know everybody is
struggling but it's the simple things
like um i mean you're not gonna like
this one but you know don't accelerate
so hard uh empty your wallet why is he
not gonna like that well you know if you
like driving fast you know accelerating
hard is going to increase your fuel
consumption um an extra 25 kilograms in
your boot is going to increase your fuel
consumption by a percentage in this hot
weather or here's a tough one um if you
put on air conditioning that will also
um increase your fuel consumption but if
you decrease it and open your windows
that can increase the drag here's morgan
sent me a text earlier could i ask when
you're talking about turning down the ac
what about his new car with the cold
seats and the hot and cold thing for his
coffee what's he supposed to do about
that very very tough and if he's if he's
got the roof down as well that could
create a drag as well yeah horrible must
be difficult in l.a moving on um
[Music]
[Laughter]
[Music]
anyway moving on uh steve the motoring
industry is there more that the motoring
industry can do not really it's too
short-term this is this has happened
very recently hasn't it and these are
the dying days of the dead tree juice i
mean the electric future is going to
happen before we know it there is one
advantage to this uh panic over uh fuel
prices though you can buy some very
tasty mortars very cheap play if you
apolo mine just bought a porsche cayenne
s with a full service history about 11
years old very nice order
2 000 of your english pounds i was again
i got offered a mercedes coupe the other
day 5 litre v8 so when you say that to
people now they're like oh my god the
only thing that won't pass is a petrol
station
the car is a thousand pounds
nobody wants those big old barges so if
you ever lusted after one now is that
electric motors
look how much the cars cost in the first
place
yes you're saving money on by plugging
it in and people are very smug about all
that and they think they're saving the
planet
but
the initial purchase price is so high
cradle to grave
if you compare crowded grade for an
electric vehicle with internal
combustion engine there's hardly any
difference in terms of saving the planet
in terms of co2 emissions do you know
what the more the greenest vehicle and
they were green so there's a clue that
was ever made was because of cradle to
grave what the world war two jeep yeah
because it's how long they keep going
for and people one of the things that
morris can do is not chop and change the
car so much
you know i mean the old days of thinking
oh it's gonna be all worn out a hundred
thousand miles
a good you know driving into the ground
just keep it until until it falls and
then if you've got a big motor these
days you're getting 500 quid for scrap
for a bigger howard um fearful uk
campaign has done such a lot of good you
always tell me that the politicians are
listening you know we've heard then
france has done it germany's done it
what do we need do do the companies need
pressure bought on them by political
leaders because there's no government in
sight that's what i mean i'm that's why
i said to the beginning i would have
thought that one of those two leadership
candidates would have thought oh this is
a really good opportunity
maybe they will i don't know are you
getting through to the politicians with
your message today well i've met with
both of them individually have you in
the long run it's going to win three
weeks uh liz is going to win with these
uh and simply this the reason is the tax
cutting issue is the big one of course
but i'm afraid that rishi is actually it
was found by bloomberg who actually
published that he wants to put a green
taxis on diesel and petrol we're already
paying the highest tax is in the world
we're already paying the highest petrol
in the world and this here's the thing
uh jeremy it's very important to
understand our second ask is well we
we've got off gem offcom off what why
haven't we got something for pump watch
there are 37 million drivers in this
country and they don't have any uh price
protection whatsoever do you believe
them both well elizabeth we all know
that do you believe her when she says
she'll get a grip of this yes or no
i think i think yes she will i i'm more
convinced i i was a fan of penny morden
i that's who i was going for because she
immediately came out and said she's
going to cut field duty obviously that's
my campaign i worry i worry about you
know the promises that they make let's
try something out watch that what's that
watch steve barry's face um i don't
upset uh cyclists
but i have absolutely no idea why
cyclists who seem to dominate our roads
nowadays and don't have to pay anything
in petrol don't have to pay road tax
themselves or get insured one has to
move about five feet out the way you get
abused they take pictures of you why
aren't they taking some responsibility
well what do you want me to say do you
agree
with every single syllable you just and
they shave their legs to go faster which
does my head in but it's true isn't it
cyclists that do not think they should
be taxed yes i should absolutely and
they should have their an mot on their
motorbike
and they should have some sort of
identification but don't say you can't
do it because we already do it in
denmark you're paying for petrol you've
got everything you want on the roads and
you don't pay any money gem what no i i
also think that they're doing what they
need to for their health as well they're
getting out they're doing exercise i
think we want to encourage people to be
doing more because i think during the
pandemic
i get that i get that but should they
not shoulder some of the burden because
motorists are shouldering a risk please
use the cycle lanes that'd be nice okay
okay are you a cyclist i'm not a cyclist
i just feel like you know what well
there's a place for people there is a
place but they're taking over our roads
and there's a velodrome that's a place
for it
yeah
so you hope this message this this this
cut that you want um in in fuel duty of
25 p you're hopeful that liz trust will
listen you're hopeful that the next
prime minister we believe it will be her
will do this because if it doesn't
happen very briefly from all three of
you what happens well we're in dire
straits it's impacting on the economy as
you made the point people are really
suffering people can't even afford to
fill their car to go to medical points
to hospitals there's that issue that's
happening they're not going to the
supermarket once a week they're going
once a month now so it's impacting on
the high street the whole thing is
costing a problem i'm
backed by the road haulage association
something like 50 of the truckers costs
is fuel unbelievable steve briefly
the economy's got to get back from the
from the pandemic people have got to get
back to work if they can't afford to
drive to the place that they do their
work how are we going to do that
brilliant guys thank you so much gemma
back tomorrow night we're talking
finances brilliant uh it is yet another
uh problem for us in the united kingdom
and next and uncensored more problems
record waiting lists diy dentistry and a
possible nurses strike to come the big
question is the nhs facing its biggest
ever emergency cheery stuff tonight
don't go away we're coming back in three
see ya
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
it can sometimes feel like the nhs is
always in crisis never more so than just
before an election but the truth is that
national health care is complicated it's
expensive and it matters and put simply
for many this is life and death stuff
and the nhs itself has arguably never
been in greater need of emergency care
the pandemic and the costs crisis have
withered a health service that was
already under serious strain and all
those performance metrics and missed
targets and dire warnings are suddenly
becoming very real very very painful
stories of suffering now nhs staff are
suffering too how could they not be
first the pandemic now all of this
this week we heard the royal college of
nursing is telling its 465 000 members
to vote to strike over pay that would be
the first time ever in england and wales
and it could bring hospitals to their
knees some of them are already there
waiting lists for routine hospitals have
fear unbelievable records of 6.6 million
people and for some and this is personal
to me waiting is deadly 10 000 people
have been waiting longer than 104 days
to start cancer treatment that is double
last year it's appalling add in waiting
times for ambulances and accident
emergency problems as well and england's
health watchdog says that people are
pulling out their own rotten teeth and
using super glue to stick in home made
replacements this is why my friends
nine yes out of every 10 nhs dental
practices are now not accepting new
adult patients the message is simple go
private or or just carry on in agony
remember all of this then is before the
expected winter chaos of flu and covid
here's a shocking real life story that
should in this day and age be
unthinkable billy taylor removed a tooth
with pliers like these now he's about to
join me for more squeamish viewers look
away billy um for everybody watching
thinking this is the united kingdom in
2022. tell me exactly what happened
hi jeremy yeah so uh we went into lock
down
and uh within about a few weeks i
started getting a bit of problem with my
tooth i had had a bit of work on it done
before and uh i started producing
abscess on the side of my face and it
got bigger and bigger um he's
excruciating pain so i phoned up the
dentist and basically said
um told them exactly that and they said
unless i can't breathe
like i literally like can't breathe at
all
then you can't come in they can't do
anything about it
i know there's a delay sorry can we just
recap the dentist who we are told we
can't name for legal reasons said unless
you can't breathe don't bother coming in
yeah they said they can't do anything at
all if you couldn't breathe you wouldn't
be able to make it wearing hands
basically um so you do this
you literally decided to take this tooth
out yourself so bad oh god
so bad was the agony i'm told you had to
drink some whiskey how painful was it
pal
yeah i mean you know if you if you've
had too fake before you'll know uh how
it can kind of affect you it's you know
it's excruciating pain and um yeah just
had to had to do it really i mean
had a bit of whiskey and then thought
let's go for it just give him a best
shot to be honest but
yeah i mean the absence could have got a
lot worse could have had an infection
which could you know could go to your
brain so it's quite serious stuff we're
dealing with
when um
it it finished the pandemic did you get
treatment in the end did you go and tell
this dentist or another dentist you
don't well no i mean i did
i
took it out the next day it started
healing and it had a full recovery in
about three days it fully sort of healed
over
the next time i saw the dentist which
was just a routine checkup uh they had a
look and they asked me who took it out i
told them i did it and they saw a bit
shocked i said well i couldn't get
couldn't see a dentist um two questions
was was that the same dentist who told
you you couldn't breathe or did you
change surgeries
yeah no i couldn't change surgery
there's no no apps i could go to really
they all sort of
they all had massive waiting lists
so tonight uh when you finish
your launch on british television right
you get toothache the big question billy
taylor would you go to a dentist or
would you do it yourself
well there we go um i'll go to a dentist
as i could see a dentist but at the
moment i
they didn't seem to be able to get hold
of them can you really that's the that's
the truth of that billy thank you so
much indeed stay there dr rona iskandar
in a second uh dr philippa kay um i know
when you walked in you said oh i'm gonna
get a hard time no uh listen rona i
wanna try and understand when you see
that yeah
what you're you're a dentist correct uh
you trained you're what what in the name
of the lord do you think when you see
that in 2022 a colleague of yours saying
if you can't breathe don't bother
ringing us ridiculous
i think it's totally unacceptable and i
think it really affirms that nhs
dentistry is at its all-time crisis this
story unfortunately is something that i
heard a lot during the pandemic so it's
not a one-off no not a one-off and
unfortunately when national lockdown
hits
i was actually spending most of my days
on the phone dealing with patients my
own patients or even patients that
weren't my own and trying to give them
advice over the phone physically
couldn't open up my dental practice we
were shot for the first three months we
couldn't see them i think i spoke to
philippa as well who also told me that a
lot of dental patients were calling up
the doctors and saying i have abscesses
i have this and dentists felt really
really powerless why are there so why
are we in the grip as we sit here and
we'll move uh to philippa in a second
about doctor's appointments you know 6.6
million people i'm waiting this why are
people unable to find a dentist
presumably that means there aren't
enough dentists and you know what i'm
going to say to you
you trained as an nhs dentist we the
taxpayer paid for that and then you've
gone private because you told my team
there's too much stress so so why are we
investing in you if you're allowed to
then disappear is not a contract well
this is the thing and i think that nhs
dentistry the problem really is the
system i went in with a lot of love and
passion for my career dentistry has the
highest suicide rate of lots of
professions the bda have found that as
well when i went in there i was given
targets and quotas by my practice these
are set out by the nhs you have to do x
amount of work that meant that sometimes
i was doing checkups in six minutes
seven minutes that is not the care that
i want to give my patients i was burning
out and i wasn't giving the quality that
they really deserved why are people
listen the way you explain i can
understand why more people aren't
getting into the profession certainly
it's yet another thing that seems to
have crept on us up on us and and is
causing massive problems are they
finding it difficult to find dentists is
that the reason because of the industry
well i think this is a great question
because actually dental schools take
about 70 dental students on average in a
year
this hasn't increased there were 70 10
years ago when i qualified and they're
70 now the crisis is getting worse why
aren't they taking on more students
again it's a funding problem and and
you're and actually you make such a
salient point i'll bring in uh dr uh
philippa k philippa this is not just
dentists this is doctors this is nurses
we heard about the royal college of
nursing saying strike i mean that's
never happened before how bad is it on
the front line for you
it's difficult and i think that we need
to remember that we don't want to
frighten people and we don't want people
to not go to hospital when they need to
you know if you are having symptoms of a
heart attack or a stroke you need to go
and we saw at the beginning of lockdown
that people weren't going when they had
cancer symptoms they were concerned if
you are in need the nhs is open it has
always been open and it is open for you
but we are six seven thousand gp shorts
we are tens of thousands of hospital
doctors and nurses why and midwives why
is it as as as ronan said and i totally
get your point you know that that you go
in there with such expectations a bit
you know it's it's something that you
want to do you want to give and the
pressure's unbearable and of course
you're going to go private completely
together people who send their kids to
private education say why would i not if
i can afford it because the system's not
great what for you as a gp i mean 6.6
million people waiting i mean it's okay
and quite proper to say don't panic
because you know my old man died a year
ago and the nhs were absolutely
unbelievable but you go out into the
waiting room and there's thousands of
people waiting and it it's not fair on
anybody isn't it it's a combination of
things and i think it's also important
to remember that when patients are
complaining and complaining about lack
of access that actually you need to be
complaining to your mp as much as you
might be complaining to your gp there is
a lack of training and there is a but
even if we opened up the medical schools
right now i'm still 10 years away from
you know having more gps on the desk
next to me and we need to be able to
retain our staff there are issues about
pension rules and doctors senior doctors
leaving early or leaving at different
times i mean i'm doing this the other
day on already some doctors or gps want
to work three days a week because they
don't they can't that a bit like you
wrote the the the pressure and the
stress the message the message that
would come across and i'm not
criticizing criticizing either of you
because you do a fantastic job it seems
to me that the very people that keep
this country going are being let down by
this country and and that for all of us
has really really bad ramifications
doesn't it you have to remember that gps
who may be working three full days are
likely to be working over 40 hours
within those three four days and that
gps lots of us i will also be appraisers
of other gps which we have to do every
year or we'll be teaching medical
students or we'll be doing other things
that have to all research that have to
be done so it's not that if you're a
portfolio gp and you work three or four
days a week it's not that people aren't
working they're working and also in any
job people have the right to work
part-time if that's what they want to do
and that's how you might retain your
staff better interesting um and of
course the private sector would be uh
more preferable for people not just the
money but the the work things that
you've talked about hours and
flexibility rona we're not looking after
in my mind dentist doctors the very
people who are supposed to look after us
how do we fix this what's your answer i
think that this is a great question and
i've been trying to get two great
questions
literally quite proud of myself well
done jess
i think the thing is really as i said
you've got to take up more dental
students we've got to provide the
funding more dentists need to go through
we need to also prepare them and for a
better work environment the other thing
is is that 2 000 dentists
left the nhs this year 2000 right and
why this isn't necessary to go private
they're leaving the profession as a
whole they cannot handle the stress of
running a practice with fulfilling these
quotas they're finding themselves
incredibly short staffed we're not
having the support system anymore you
know nurses receptionists etc we know
they're short
across the board so we really need to
provide an environment that's conducive
to providing optimal health care um
billy i think i think it's really um
really uh philip sorry in terms of the
way you look at this whole thing i guess
as a medical professional you think
people are honest the whole time we care
we want to do our best to sum up really
as ronnie said
what's your message to people if they
are in pain can't get a gp's appointment
they can't get a dentistry they're
sitting at home they can't put pets in
their car they can't afford this it's a
nightmare healthcare i would have
thought to this country is one of the
most important things it's going to get
worse as we said in the winter what's
your message philippa first thing is to
do is to look after yourself that means
you take up your covered vaccine your
flu vaccine if it's offered to you and
all of those things you attend your
cervical screening and your breast
screening because catching things early
or prevention is better than cure and
from a financial point of view it costs
less to the nhs as well never mind the
huge personal cost so there are
definitely things that you can do you
also need to use the nhs wisely and that
might mean that you talk to your
pharmacist first pharmacists are often a
really underused resource that's true
that you use your walk-in centre and
your local minor injuries clinic and
your gp and not just go to a e straight
away so we have to use it carefully but
if you have chest pain if you have
stroke if you have symptoms related to
cancer then you need to ring your gp and
yes you might be talking to a
receptionist first but you need to say
this is what i'm concerned about and you
will be put forward because we are
triaging that means that we are dealing
with the people in most need first do
you both think that there are some
dentists and doctors who are having it
too easy when the country looks on and
is suffering
no no i think my qualities are working
incredibly incredibly um hard under a
time of immense pressure on the
background of two years of a pandemic
i had to be in hospital um some months
ago and the response was incredible and
i and i think that we have to balance it
i think we do have to balance it because
the people who do that job but you
wouldn't advocate that would you no
definitely definitely not and i think
the thing is as well just to echo what
philippa says is that you know i
sometimes speak to dentists that are
newly qualified have been two years into
practice and they call me up in tears
because they simply cannot cope and the
restrictions that we had to work in
afterwards you know we had to allow
surgeries to air for an hour between
patients so we couldn't see enough
patients the ppe i mean literally you
looked like the michelin man you know it
was so uncomfortable and you know these
just weren't great conditions and we are
here to provide health you know we care
about our patients i really really
appreciate it billy and devon as well
thank you very much indeed um i think
it's really easy as i said to to
criticize and say this isn't good enough
and it isn't but i think it's also
really important
to say that the service that people like
you do is is so important thank you for
joining us tonight can i have an
appointment tomorrow morning at nine
o'clock we've got two things
or nhs anything for you there we go
still to come and uncensored it's the
dog days of the tory leadership race but
they're still my friends another four
weeks to go
my feeling is as so many other people
agree shouldn't they just put us out of
our misery put this trust into 10
downing street and get on with running
this country tory party deputy chairman
matt vick has been in the job three
weeks he's live after this break i'm
coming right back
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
this is talk tv
[Music]
right last night talk tv hosted the tory
leadership hustings in darlington a
veritable cornerstone in the former red
wall this trust and ritchie sunac traded
barbs on tax on levelling up and the
cost crisis but it was presented tom
newton dunn's comments at the end of his
interview with liz trust that stole the
headlines the foreign secretary was
caught on mike apologizing to our tom
for criticizing the media tom rightly
called her out and said it's cheap have
a look
i'm sorry to read about the media
meanwhile rishi sunat worth 730 million
quid by the way tried to find common
ground with his northern audience dish
rishi told them when he's eating out to
help out he quite enjoys the palmo uh
for the uninitiated here a palmo is a
time-side takeaway favorite involving a
giant slab of breaded chicken covered in
white sauce and cheese now i'm not
utterly convinced that's your really
your dish rish great uh tom also asked
both candidates if they'd be prepared to
work together to solve britain's cost
crisis trust snipe that sunac's plans
were quote gordon brown economics um i'd
say a bit like that although i don't
agree with this it all got quite tasty
i'm delighted though to be joined now by
deputy conservative party chairman and
mp for stockton good friend of mine matt
vickers good evening matt how are you
good evening jeremy i'm fanta it's
coming at you loud and clear from costa
del stockman it's been glorious up here
today we've been out on the doorsteps
it's fantastic i'm upbeat i'm happy uh
let's start with the palmo because i've
read something very interesting matt
vickers sent a letter to the
parliamentary catering team last year
asking to include the traditional t-side
delicacy on its list of culinary options
in tuesday's hastings russia sunac
praised you for putting the palmo on the
menu in parliament and he said we won't
just be serving them in parliament we'll
be serving them off the cabinet table in
downing street i mean celebrity chef
matt vickers what's going on man
if you had a palmer yet jeremy it's
absolutely fantastic basically i went
down there to westminster and noticed
that when you know you see this
fantastic menu with all these wonderful
culinary dishes from all over the world
there for mps parliamentarians and peers
to eat and i decided why not a dish from
tea side the farmer wonderful stuff and
actually my mission down there was
getting the palmer on their menu and
getting t-side on their menu as well so
they can get spend some cash up here and
get you know some of my issues dealt
with right let's get serious my friend
um
i'm gonna put to you the deputy uh
conservative party chairman i know
you've only been in the job a week you
were you were very supportive of boris
johnson you haven't come out to declare
for either liz trust or rishi sooner
although you were involved in his
election his richmond constituency um
to a lot of people in this country and
this is what i want to direct answer to
we're watching an elongated
mess
that is
i don't know they trade barbs every day
they both seem to make promises that
none of us can quite work out whether
those are attainable do you not think
the british people right now
need a government to be active to be
available to be out there telling us
that these horrendous things be it the
cost of living at petrol food polio
today
do you not think our government needs to
govern put this to bed and get on with
doing what we the british people need
man
i think democracy is a really important
thing and i actually think it's right
that those two people who will be in
down one of whom will be in downing
street running this country is
travelling the length and breadth of
this country talking to conservative
party members being asked the questions
that matter to the people in stockton in
darlington last night i think that's a
healthy thing i think that's a good
thing and i think it should be stress
tested i think that we should be put on
the put on the spot and questioned about
the issues that affect the people around
here and i think that's entirely the
right thing to do do i think there are
lots of issues going on in the country
exactly and that's why it's so important
that we get the right person but of
course
i get that
i get that matt but you might have heard
the last sectionality put this in real
terms for you
i i'm speaking to
before the break a dentist so stressed
by the the conditions of being an nhs
dentist she quit a doctor who is part of
a workforce that's shrinking that's got
a 6.6 million long waiting list and a
man who unable to see a dentist
took his own teeth out with pliers i'm
not being against democracy
our government has in many people's eyes
disappeared and needs to be more on the
front foot helping us at this moment
that's what i'm saying to you and i
think whatever your policies and
whatever side wins actually the british
people are getting fed up because they
think we're being left in the mire on
our own map that's the point
in real terms our our waiting lists are
through the roof we had a pandemic where
people couldn't get elected surgery
couldn't access the things that they
might have the nhs under massive
pressure are amazing nhs by the way that
delivers fantastic services those
amazing men and women who work at my
local hospital deliver unbelievable
quality of care and actually you know
what there are almost i think we're on
12 11 800 more nurses in those hospitals
than they were a year ago there are 4
300 more doctors in those hospitals than
they were just a year ago the nhs is
getting the biggest cash boost in its
entire history but man did you know what
that would be
how do we make it go further
matt i know there's a delay
i i understand when you work in
government about sound bites what i'm
asking is does the tory government right
now understand the depths of concern the
depth of fear fear that people will not
be able to heat their homes fear that
they won't be able to fill their cars to
get to work fear that they'll have to
what take their own teeth out fear that
there will be blackouts we've read that
today what i'm saying is i'm not trying
to over dramatize it i'm trying to say
that a majority of people in this
country are looking at what's going on
and going whether it's rishi sunak or
liz truss i want my government to tell
me how the hell i'm going to pay my
electricity bill come january that's
what i'm saying mate yeah
you
yeah you couldn't over dramatize the
impact of the cost of living to me
every day today i was out on the
doorsteps hearing from people in my part
of the world seeing the bills that are
landing on those doormats that are
through the roof this isn't a uk problem
this is a global problem called we all
know all the causes of it whether it be
the war in ukraine uh whether it be the
the unlock from kovid all of the zero
covered policies of china all those
things had a massive impact it's
affecting the globe these these prices
and what is the government doing well
it's focusing you know what the
government doesn't grow money on trees
it has the money that you pay in tax
that i pay in tax and everyone else at
home pays in tax so when we give it to
somebody to support them we take it from
somebody else and those are fine
balancing acts but what we are doing is
ensuring that what the
those most vulnerable in society get as
much as 1 600 pounds extra in the pocket
and that's entirely the right thing to
do that money hasn't all reached
everybody yet there is money that will
appear in october for pensioners whether
that be you know there's an increase of
300 winter fuel allowance does that
matt
is it final question a good look for the
tory party the party that's supposed to
tax and and spend prudently that the
party that's supposed to care what i
find astonishing and i'm going to stick
up for rushing sunak here he stands up
and he talks about prudence in terms of
tax and inflation almost thatcherite it
seems from what we read that the tory
faithful have turned against that i fear
that the tory party if they continue to
rip themselves to shreds and whether
they say they care about the british
people they are perceived to not have
their eyes on the game i fear that that
will affect them long term and i'm
asking you as the deputy chair does your
party and does your government
understand the depth the depth of misery
suffering and concern right now not just
in darlington but across the country
matt because that's the question
i think we're very well aware we're out
on the streets every day hearing the
challenges that people people are facing
and that's exactly why those candidates
are traveling around the country hearing
the pressures hearing the challenges
that people face in different parts of
this country and how very tough these
times are but you know what we got
through that pandemic we've got the
doors open on the economy again we've
got people still in work during that
pandemic we've paid 13 and a half
million people's wages that has to be
paid down somehow and now we're getting
to the other end we're dealing with the
problems the impact that's had on our
hospitals the impacts had on our kids in
school with it and the impacts had on
our economy uh big challenges we've we
got through the brexit thing we got
through the pandemic and now we're
dealing with recovering from that
pandemic and getting this country moving
again and you know what we're going to
be optimistic and we're going to get on
with the job with whichever one of those
fantastic candidates we select to be the
next
right actually i've got two more very
quickly and it's a one-word answer uh
who wins rishi sunak or liz trust
oh that's a convenient you know what i'm
entitling neutral i'm not allowed okay
i'm not allowed otherwise i'm sure
they're both great candidates do you
know what the labour party would love to
have a female right
you've got 30 seconds to promote
something that i think is fantastic tell
us about your campaign for posthumous
awards for world war one soldiers and
fair play to you 30 seconds go matt
because it's the most important campaign
i've probably ever ran i know about a
guy from stockton called george hunter
he had an industrial he worked at a
foundry up in port clarence he suffered
from an industrial accident still put
himself forward to going to world war
one was sent off to france leaving his
wife and children behind he was shot at
dawn
because his behavior as a result this
industrial action
made them seem as a troubled causer
he was pardoned we pardoned him people
looked at the evidence and said that was
completely wrong and now he deserves
those medals and i'm going to do
everything i can to get him those medals
good man uh matt uh thank you for that
take your palmo with you and coming up
next jesus journoves are fired up and
ready to fulbright fume all over today's
debates the legend that is kevin
o'sullivan and an affair hagen next to
an uncensored see in a minute
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
do
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
welcome back to uncensored with me jake
i'm joined now by my fabulous jesus
journalist tonight talk tv legendary
presenter kevin o'sullivan and talk to
the contributor of fear hagen or mrs h
as i love to call her welcome how are
you i'm good how are you i'm good nice
to see you kev uh so the big question uh
extraordinary to think in 2022 are we
going to see blackouts at christmas this
year probably yes really yes i think the
government preparing people preparing
saying you know perhaps we might have
problems with power of power we only
have a sixth of the power that we need
i think yes the government should be
preparing people growing up in scotland
i remember there was a winter where we
did have blackouts for about two months
i'm not really sure why i asked my mom
she can remember why either but we had
to deal with that and scotland it was
really really freezing oh
then you put money wait hold on a minute
hold on where's my button
look oh there he is kev o's sullivan as
i never saw it before rob put the money
in the meter man
well you get paid enough right listen
sick of that guy um kev honestly 2022
places running out of water petrol we
can't afford to put in our cars blackout
what is this 94 why why has all of this
seemingly just come and jumped at us was
there no forward planning what's going
on we've had incoherent energy policies
for a long long time we've got a perfect
storm uh ukraine russian russia cutting
off the gas
our green policies which have left us uh
rather um
susceptible to uh fluctuating global uh
situations
and the economy and therefore what's
going to happen is hospitals and food
outlets food manufacturers have already
been told get your generators ready
because we are going to almost certainly
have to impose
strategic blackouts on the country now
the last time this happened i'm young
i'm young enough
old enough i was only a little kid but i
do remember ted heath he had to do the
same back in the 1970s and once a
politician a government has to impose
turning the lights out that government
is out it with the if if we have
blackouts the government will lose the
next election well i think this is the
end of the game for the tourists this
has happened i mean it civil unrest i'm
not sure i'm just being honest i mean if
i
if you lay it out people can't pay their
bills they're not going to have a
lecture i mean yeah where does it end
briefly and this is the thing is that
kevin you're absolutely right this is
the end of this government and actually
people need to realize they need to stop
voting for the tory party stop voting
what's the obsession i've had this
argument last night this is it's a very
good point but you're right civil unrest
is not too far down the road if people
can't pay their bills if they can't put
food on the table they can't heat their
homes they can't feed their children
where else do they go and they can only
um
you know make the voices have by going
to the ballot box and that's not for
another couple of years well we've said
it yes
i said it to you this morning this
rudderless government i don't believe
that anybody should get into number 10
down the street without a mandate from
the people people disagree we've got
fuel prices we were talking about this
today we've got i mean i did this
graphic last night you know electricity
and gas from like 127 quid a year later
four thousand two hundred what do you
think will happen to the people of this
country well the problem is uh they're
talking about civil disobedience it will
be enforced civil disobedience because
it's not a question of people saying
these bills are too high we refuse to
pay them this is a protest they will
refuse to pay them because they simply
can't pay them the abyss we are staring
into is unprecedented i'm not sure this
government's got a handle on it uh but i
also don't think that the answer is to
vote labor it certainly isn't that well
the answer is not to vote to keep voting
conservatives and also i don't
understand well that's why
the labor party should be straight to
heaven
they should be taking advantage of this
opportunity but they used to and well
yes because kiyosama is useless
absolutely agreed you know and there's
lots of people who are politically
homeless because the labour party they
couldn't organize a party in a brewery
what are they doing they should be using
this as well they organized a party and
he got away with it
very quickly not really well there we go
tom daley's new documentary about
homophobia in the commonwealth just 30
seconds briefly is he right is he wrong
he's right and he's wrong a lot of
homophobia in lots of those countries
that he talks about 30-something
countries was actually already there
before
colonialism before the empire and you're
from ghana and that's one of the
countries involved which is really
shameful um but a lot of these things
were culturally unacceptable and then
the empire came and put them into law
and i think that's what he means when he
was talking about the empire didn't uh
make it easier you know they kind of
um
he tried to blame britain there are 56
countries in the commonwealth but a lot
of 35
35 of them ban homosexuality
14 of them are under direct british law
and in all of those uh colonies the
directly ruled british colonies
homosexuality is legal so to break blame
britain uh for other countries laws is
just ludicrous all right kev you had a
heated discussion with a climate
activist today can we just watch this
clip this is brilliant
it's what is known dylan as a nice sunny
summer day it is not a prelude to the
end of the world did you get that
it is a nice day it's not the end of the
world
yes i
can you believe that do you enjoy the
weather yeah i think these people are
doomsday cultists they hate the whole
idea of joy of people enjoying anything
it's sunny it's the end of the world no
it's not and eve hot days even those
very hot days we had a couple of weeks
ago certainly do not prove that climate
change uh has reached a critical point
if at all the problem kevin because they
actually they don't they don't they do
that
97
of climate scientists agree
that
global warming is caused by humans by
you you can but why that would why not
it's factual that the earth is warming
and that's proven by the woman it's not
necessarily ours but it's not
necessarily can i can i jump in because
i'd love to talk to you two forever
maybe we'll go down the pub but listen
i'm a serious no you know i get the
whole idea we should be concerned about
the climate and i'm not just siding with
my mate i think there are more pressing
problems right now to get dealt with
rather than worrying and i think that
green levy i love you mrs h but i gotta
go please come back won't you oh well
fear hagen thank you very much the
legend that is kev o'sullivan back
tomorrow morning ten o'clock on talk tv
uh almost uh five tonight so we're
standing by for the talk uh which will
be on after uh nine o'clock that's it
from me uh what a day it was from thomas
the tank engine to kev o'sullivan all in
16 hours wherever you are tonight keep
it uncensored have yourselves a great
wednesday we'll see you back here
tomorrow night at eight o'clock
[Music]
join me ian collins every day on talk tv
there is nothing we hate more than
hypocrisy discussing the big issues why
was it so hard to establish the deputy
leader was at a meeting with her
colleagues the callers allen in brisbane
tracy in burton on trent dave thank you
very much picking apart
the big stuff this simply does not wash
look who's back under the spotlight
this is talk tv news
good evening i'm emily rose adams ryan
giggs's ex-girlfriend has told a court
their relationship was relentlessly
awful towards the end and she was a
slave to his needs the ex-footballer
denies charges of assault and using
abusive and controlling behavior and his
lawyers say kate grievel's claims are a
complete pack of lies
a 47 year old man has died and three
people have been injured in a series of
incidents involving a firearm in the
highlands police scotland say they think
they're all linked and a 39 year old man
is in custody and the rac claims
supermarkets aren't passing on lower
fuel prices to customers that's despite
a significant drop in the price of
wholesale fuel they estimate that petrol
should be about 14 pence cheaper per
liter than it is right now that's all
for now we'll have more updates after
the talk
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
foreign